ما تنظر إليه هو أصول
حدث فائق الانتشار محتمل أن
ثمانية أشخاص على الأقل ، بمن فيهم
الرئيس دونالد ترامب نفسه ، مصابون الآن
، وهذا من بين أولئك الذين
لديهم القدرة على الاختبار فعليًا ،
لا يمكنك رؤية الفيروس ولكن ماذا
يحدث خلال حدث شديد الانتشار ،
فأنت تعلم أنه تشبيه تقريبي للغاية ولكن
إذا فكرنا في نيران المخيم وقلنا
أن هذا الشخص قد
أصيب بالفيروس وأطلقه
، فليس الأمر كما لو أن الحلقة المحيطة
بالشخص ستكون في الواقع
المخاطرة هم أولئك الموجودون
على الجانب حيث يتم عرض المزيد من الفيروس
إما من خلال
التحدث أو من خلال الهواء
الذي ينفخه هناك ،
لكن هذه اللحظات أيضًا هي التي
لفتت انتباه المحلل الطبي
CNN آرون برومج
عندما انتهى الحدث عندما  كلهم
قادمون ومعانقة
ومصافحة ويقولون
التهاني إذا كنت شخصًا يراهن على
أن أضع
أموالي في المكان الذي حدث فيه هذا.  كان
بروتوكول السلامة للحدث هو
اختبار أي شخص على مقربة من
الرئيس ،
لكن لم يكن ذلك مطلوبًا لجميع
الحاضرين
، ومن الواضح أنه لم يكن مضمونًا مرة أخرى
، ألق نظرة هنا حيث كان الأشخاص الذين
تم تشخيص إصابتهم بالإيجابية يجلسون
ليس بجانب بعضنا البعض مما يقودنا إلى
النظر مرة أخرى إلى ما حدث قبل ذلك
مباشرة وبعد أن
تميل مستشارة البيت الأبيض السابقة كيليان
كونواي عن كثب للتحدث مع
المدعي العام ويليام بار ، وقد
يكون من الصعب تحديد ذلك.  هذه
الأحداث الموزعة الفائقة في
هذا الحفل الواحد تعطينا
نظرة على
التشريح لكيفية حدوثه طوال الوقت ليس فقط
هنا
ولكن في أي وقت يتجمع الناس معًا في
مجموعات كبيرة
في منتصف الجائحة ، فلا
شك في أنه كان هناك
انتقال في  الاحتجاج
على التجمعات السياسية إنها مجرد حقيقة
أن الفيروس لا يميز
لمجرد أننا لم نوثق هذا
لا يعني  لم يحدث
هذا فقط لأن لدينا حدثًا
الآن مرئيًا جدًا
وموثقًا جيدًا تم اختباره جيدًا ونحن
نرى النتيجة منه